what happened during the void century
what is the will of d and what actually
is the one piece a couple more years one
last saga it's really hard to believe
that one piece is coming to a close soon
allegedly at least with 25 years of
publication it started to seem like the
story would just go on forever but all
good things must come to an end even if
oda sensei is being a little bit let's
say optimistic about his estimates
however what's even harder to believe is
how many open questions we still have to
be answered how many mysteries still
need solving how many people and places
and events we still have to see in the
story and so i took to twitter and
together with you we found 146
things that we still need to see before
the end of one piece and so let's start
with what many fans think will be the
setting of the next arc we still need to
see elbaf the land of the giants and
concerning elbaf we still have a few
questions like who is loki the prince
that big ma mentioned whole cake island
who lola was engaged to will we meet
other norse mythology inspired
characters like thor or odin well
actually i guess we already met odin and
wano so that might be a bit too many
otis for one story in big mom's
flashback we also saw what appeared to
be a massive tree on the island is this
the fabled adam tree we also know that
while the giants have a strong
connection to norse mythology a certain
red-haired pirate who still needs to
reunite with luffy also has a viking
inspired ship so we have to ask what is
shanks's connection to elbaf and before
we reach the final destination love tale
we're still missing one road poneglyph
where is it is it on elbaf before we get
into all the action here a quick word
from the also very action-packed sponsor
of today's video bloodline heroes of
lithius bloodline heroes of lithius is a
free-to-play card-based fantasy rpg in
3d realistic graphics where you can not
only collect champions build kingdoms
but also create legendary heirs to your
houses by combining the forces of
various bloodlines such as orcs listens
demons and dragonborn i think that in
many ways it's the classic gotcha
experience hitting all the points that
are important to me like it's beautiful
and unique artwork and the wide variety
of characters but bloodline stood out to
me especially for how interesting the
stories and world building are because
next to just the classic warrior role
you can also choose to go down the road
of politician or a merchant while you
build your empire and since it's even
possible to create hybrid characters my
favorite one is probably the hybrid air
so if you also want to fill the void of
boredom between one piece chapters with
something really fun and exciting i'm
sure you will really enjoy this game so
make sure to get it using this qr code
or by clicking the link and using the
code in the description below for some
exclusive in-game rewards and speaking
of love talo we obviously have a load of
questions about this mysterious island
as well the first being well where
exactly is it and what was so
outrageously funny that it ended up with
laugh in its name what exactly was roger
too early for in arriving there alberth
and love tale are the two islands the
straw hats absolutely 100 still needs to
visit before the end of one piece
however there are still loads of other
locations that we're wondering about one
place in particular that we need to
learn a lot about is god valley but
we'll probably only get to see anything
about it through flashbacks we probably
won't visit this location in person on
account that it's completely disappeared
which raises the questions what's
happened on god valley and why did it
vanish but these three places are far
from the only ones we still have
questions about other places we're still
curious about but aren't necessarily
likely to get answers before the end of
the story include lodestar islands and
the mystery and its importance in
teaching pirates about the ponoglyphs
the fabled emerald city a mythic place
on par with the golden city on skypia
and where and what was the thing that we
saw sucking cabone [ __ ] and the fire
tank pirates into the sky also before we
saw buggy get imprisoned nimple down he
was searching for captain john's
treasure where and what is that treasure
does it have anything to do with his
recent promotion in rank oh also quick
shout out to vin and tevio the two
subscribers of the day both having me
helped increase my bouncy closer to 100
million berries in overtaking treble and
it's not just places we haven't been to
that we have questions about what about
those islands we have been to questions
like why is it always day on end's lobby
how were the gates of justice
constructed my personal vote goes to the
unspeakable power of awakened pueno what
were the giant silhouettes we saw in the
florian triangle where are they building
the bridge on tequila wolf too how will
luffy destroy fishman islands what
happens during the reverie on marijuana
how was the red line created what was
sunisha's punishment that led to zou
moving around for centuries how were
wanos borders closed and let's not
forget the ever important moon you know
sometimes i do feel bad for anime only
watchers because they don't get to ask
questions like why are there seven moons
are the sky islanders from the moon what
is nl doing up there with the space
pirates and an army of automatons okay
let me catch a breath here that's 31
questions so far for those of you who
are creeping score and those are only
questions about the geography of one
piece but what about the over 1 000
characters of the story well we have
plenty of questions about those too some
important characters exist only in
legend we haven't even seen them and yet
they have an impressive presence in the
series the first that comes to mind is
roxty zabek who is he what was his goal
how did he gather such a powerful crew
and what was his ultimate fate and what
about the greatest scientific mind of
the world government the creator of the
pacifista and the artificial devil
fruits who is dr vegapunk along a
similar line we also have skopper gabon
where is the pirate king's third in
command was he crocus's mysterious
samurai friend oh and yeah who is
charlotte's snack there is a whole sweet
commander that we never got to see on
whole cake islands and while we're super
curious about these mysterious figures
who've yet to be properly introduced
we're also missing some of our old
friends that we just know will play a
role in the story to come
some of these we're bound to hear from
very very soon and others we might be
waiting a while but in the meantime we
have to ask where exactly is zabo right
now what happened to vivi what happened
to moria what's the status of the
shichibukai who were being hunted by the
world government so where is mihawk
where's boa hancock and what about
weevil oh yeah and is edward weevil
actually whitebeard's son no you do have
to admit that the mustache resemblance
is uncanny and what about the people
that he's after where are the remaining
division commanders of the whitebeard
pirates what role is crocodile gonna
play at the end of the story and what is
the big secret from his past that
ivankov threatened him with where is
o'rouge the member of the worst
generation we probably know the least
about with all of his peers being really
fleshed out at this point surely he also
has a role to play in the future as well
there are also still a lot of loose ends
to tie up from recent arcs some other
characters we'd still like to check upon
on for example how will charlotte
katakuri factor into the future of one
piece will he ally with luffy in the
final war what happened to the fishman
pirates after whole cake island did they
survive big mom's onslaught speaking of
which what's happened to big mom's
children who came to wano after they
were knocked off the waterfall twice oh
and uh speaking of big mom are big mom
and kaido gone dead forever in most
series this wouldn't be a question given
their current status of being submerged
in lava but this is one piece we're
talking about and they might just have
the will to survive on their side what
about the characters we haven't seen in
a really long time we already mentioned
enel a little bit when we talked about
the moon but i'm talking back even
further than that all the way to the
east blue where did axe hand morgan
escape to after his cover story when
will jin finally reunite with the crew
and will we see the most important
character in the entire series again
gaimon well probably a love tale since
he of course is the one piece and then
finally in this category we of course
have plenty of characters who we've just
seen relatively recently and who are
certainly gonna play an important role
in the final saga but who still have a
ton of mystery around them most recently
we have of course buggy how the hell did
he become a yonko and in wano we still
have a lot of questions about toki
primarily why did she jump into the
future from the void century in the
first place and who was she there what
about bonnie and kuma who we saw in the
reverie what is their connection we know
that kuma was a revolutionary but why
was his epithet the tyrant and why did
he agree to vegapunk's experimentation
also since bonnie can manipulate her age
how old is she really and who is she
really and speaking of kumo what about
the enigmatic leader of the
revolutionaries and luffy's absentee
father dragon why did he abandon his son
what is his absolute goal as leader of
the revolutionary army and what's his
devil fruit power the prevailing theory
is that he holds a wind or storm type
fruit but this has yet to be confirmed
and if kaido turned out to be a fish
then who knows what misdirection oda may
be employing here what about the enemies
of the revolutionaries the world
government there's still so much mystery
surrounding this entire organization as
a whole as well so before the end of the
series we still need to know what is the
ssg who is the leader of sort is tashigi
actually connected to kuina in some way
or is their resemblance simply
coincidence how about the admirals where
in the world did they conscript fujitora
and ryokugyu from both of them are
absolute powerhouses that the government
just plucked from out of nowhere
originally the prevailing theory was
that fujitora and maybe green bull were
from wano but does that still seem
likely will we get the backstory of any
of the admirals did aokiji actually
leave the marines or is he just spying
on blackbeard who are the gorosei we do
know virtually nothing about these
shadowy figures that helm the world
governments how old are they actually do
they have powers or do they serve in
purely a non-combative role and then of
course who is emu the true hidden ruler
of the world government and the world as
a whole how old are they what powers do
they have and since we recently learned
about the gorosei's special secret
french shanks we still need to ask why
is he able to just waltz into marijuana
for a meeting with the gorosei did he
know the importance of the nika fruit
when he stole it from the world
governments what are his true intentions
or allegiances how powerful is shanks
really and perhaps the most pressing
question of them all is shanks the
father of makino's baby how about the
man who left chang's with his trademark
scar luffy's biggest rival for the
pirate king's crown blackbeards before
the end of the series we still need to
know marshall d teaches backstory what
is his connection to rox given that he
named his ship the razor the saber not
the razor thus the saber of zebek why
does he know so much about the world and
what is his ultimate goal and of course
the most mysterious of all why doesn't
he sleep and how can he have two devil
fruit powers if you're still keeping
track at home that brings us to 90
mysteries yet to be solved in the series
but we're far from done yet all of these
people and places still don't get into
the core mysteries of one piece what is
the true history of this world we still
need to know what has happened during
the void century what is the true past
of the world governments and what was
the ancient kingdom that they clashed
with what was the great cleansing that
led to the presumed end of this ancient
kingdom in wano we learned a whole lot
about luffy's devil fruit but for every
answer that we received we had more
questions pop up in their place luffy is
definitely the next joy boy or just joy
boy but we still have to wonder who was
joy boy or is joy boy and did the giant
straw hat in marijuana belong to him
originally we do know that luffy's fruit
wasn't actually the gumu gumu no me it
turned out to secretly be the hitohitomi
model nika all along but who or what is
the sun god's nika in this world and
speaking of his very special fruit we
still need a certain dr vegapunk to
explain to us what exactly double fruits
are in the first place we still kind of
don't really know what about luffy's
other special powers that go beyond his
amazing feats of hockey or devil fruit
usage what is the will of d and the
secret behind his and so many other
characters mysterious middle initial
what is the voice of all things and why
can luffy hear it thanks to sukiyaki's
and robin's conversation in the latest
chapter we also just learned that the
ancient weapon pluton is located in wano
paying off a mystery that was introduced
all the way back in alabasta we've
learned quite a bit about shirahoshi aka
poseidon but what are the ancient
weapons what was their purpose we know
that pluton is a battleship of some kind
but who created it and while we're at it
who created the other mysterious massive
boat to noah and for as much as we've
heard about the pluton and poseidon
we've learned absolutely nothing about
uranus what and where is this final
weapon and then of course we're missing
the ultimate mystery the treasure that
luffy has been searching for since
chapter one and the title of the story
what is the one piece before we get into
the most interesting questions though
there are still some other miscellaneous
things that simply need to happen before
the end of the series we still need to
know what the egg was on the oro jackson
we still need to see the open omis
immortality surgery come into play in
some whale form we need to see the grand
fleet reappear during the final war and
there are a few things that aren't super
necessary but we'd really really really
like to see them so get your pen and
paper and start writing those letters to
oda a lot of fans would love to see
another davey bad fight for instance but
with higher stakes we'd also love to see
the thousand sonny's clebautimon make an
appearance as well and while we're now
clearly in the era of god usopp i really
would do a lot to see soggy king just
one last time before the end i mean
people really want to see god valley but
i'm partial to sniper island here
honestly and hey if they made it to
skypia surely the straw hats can make it
into your heart well this brings us to a
whopping 115 mysteries we need solved
and things we need to see in the final
saga of one piece but there is still a
one very important category to go things
that still need to be resolved with the
straw hat crew themselves we've spent 25
years following the adventures of luffy
and his crew each of the straw hats has
a dream and we just know we'll see them
achieve their goals by the end of one
piece puerto rio we still haven't got an
explanation about his missing eye for
instance we also got some massive hints
but no confirmation that he has
relatives in wano hoda went out of his
way to deny that zaro's father was
ushimaru the daimyo of ringo but if not
ushimaru then who and now that he's been
wielding oda's black blade enma we'd
love to see him forge a black blade of
his own oh and what was with his
standoff with the grim reaper of course
now that he's presumably conquered death
he still has an even more formidable foe
to defeat as well before the end we need
to see zorro take on mihawk and become
the greatest swordsman in the world
usopp also has plenty of goals to
accomplish as well he has plenty of lies
that still need to come true we'd love
to see him landing a force of 8 000 men
preferably giants of course become a
true warrior of the sea and reunite with
his father yasuo the chef of the crew
sanji still owes us some answers as well
his explanation for his firepowers is
his burning passion and many have
theorized that it has something to do
with lunarian dna but we still need a
straightforward explanation why the hell
can you conjure fire sanji and for
someone so obsessed with romance will he
ever find love and reunite with viola or
pudding or help nami but more
importantly than his love for women is
his love for cooking so we need to see
him finally find the sea that he's
always dreamed of the all blue we don't
really have too many questions about
nami herself but given that she was
adopted after being found by belmeyer we
could still ask where she's originally
from and who her parents are it doesn't
really matter but given that we've
gotten a lot of extra backstory for
sanji and zoro recently and everyone on
our crew seems to secretly have special
parents for some reason it could very
much still happen what absolutely needs
to happen is that nami needs to achieve
her dream of completing a map of the
entire world with chopper we still have
a few questions about his own fruit
we've speculated that his monster point
is a forced awakening but we could still
use some confirmation from oda here also
given that we've only ever really seen
him as a human reindeer hybrid we have
to ask can chopper go full human form i
mean i don't really want to see it
because it would probably be uncanny and
terrifying but i still do have to ask by
the end of the series though our
favorite doctor still needs to cure the
world's diseases maybe he won't get
every single one but a great one for him
to cure for instance would be the
laughing side effect of the smile fruits
allowing him to further restore the
country of wano with robin most of her
big mysteries we've already covered in
the section about the true history since
that's basically her dream to uncover
the true history however there's still a
very pressing questions where is her
cowgirl hat we can only pray that her
signature hat makes the return in the
final saga in order for us to uncover
all that true history she also needs to
find the remainder of the pony glyphs
and decipher them all given that we just
now basically found out what the very
first poneglyph we saw in alabaster set
it would be really nice if oda could
give us some translation of the other
pony glyphs as well frankie isn't too
mysterious of a figure he kind of lets
it all hang out sometimes a little bit
too literally i feel but before the end
of the series we're sure to see him sail
his dreamship the thousand sunny around
the globe brooke our favorite skeletal
musician obviously has to reunite with
laboon but we'd also like to see how the
number one bob being sake fits in with
the entire story as has been highly
speculated especially in regards to love
tale and the one piece we don't really
have too many questions about jinbe
either but we do want to see him achieve
his goal of brokering peace between
fishermen and humans as well as seeing
the fishman return to the surface we
also don't have too many questions for
yamato except who her mother is but we
do have a lot of questions about our
captain monkey d luffy such as who is
his mother and is it crocodile and while
we're at it who is his grandma because
we don't know who dragon's mom slash
garb's wife partner was either we also
need to see him reunite with his mentor
shanks as well as return his signature
straw hats in a moment that's sure to
leave the fans around the world in tears
we also still need to get confirmation
on what the mysterious dream that he
shares with rogers and last but
certainly not least we need to see luffy
become the king of the pirates oh and
actually for luffy's mom well there is
this extremely well theory out there
that you really shouldn't miss